[Music]
hello friends and welcome to
i'd like to know where we answer your
bible questions and if you have some
bible questions that you'd like to send
us
you can send those to tv some tv dot
org well today you can see i'm all by
myself all by my lonesome
uh pastor bohr and pastor c.a murray um
had other engagements actually pastor
murray is still in panama
and so they've left me alone to steer
the ship
we have several questions we're going to
be looking at this afternoon
questions that you've sent in that we're
going to seek to answer from the bible
but before we do that
let's begin with a word of prayer
father in heaven thank you so much for
your word
which is able to keep us steady in
the various waves that are tossing to
and fro in this world today
james talks about not being driven and
tossed by the waves of this world and we
just pray right now that your word can
keep us steady that it can be an anchor
to our vessels
and that you can guide us and give us
answers to those questions that we have
there are several questions that have
been brought to us today from the
viewers
and i'm just asking your spirit will
lead us and direct us to the answers
in your word so do that for us we pray
be with each of the viewers
and guide and direct their hearts we
pray in jesus name
amen all right so we've got a number of
questions
as i mentioned earlier the first one
actually relates to our sabbath school
lesson it relates to isaiah chapter 65
it says could you please explain
chapter 65 as it relates to the new
heavens
and the new earth and i'm pretty sure
though it's not specific
why this question was asked uh in
chapter 65 it talks about the new
heavens and the new earth and then it
has this verse this
difficult challenging verse in verse 20
of isaiah 65 that says
in the new heavens and the new earth
supposedly there will be no more thants
and infant of days nor an old man
that has not fulfilled his days for the
child shall die in hundred years old
but the sinner being a hundred years old
shall be accursed that's just kind of a
difficult
verse i've struggled with that verse for
many years
and the answer that verse is not
actually found
well let me put it this way we covered
this in our sabbath school lesson
so basically what you're going to find
is the answer to this is going to be
covered in next
sabbath's saddle school lesson and that
sabbath school lesson covers isaiah 65
and isaiah 66
and pastor bohr has given some excellent
insights actually established some
principles
that really answer this question or at
least
the question that may be addressed here
in the chapter of isaiah 65 but if
that's not the question you're asking
about i65 you'll be happy to know that
the
sabbath school lesson march 27 sabbath
school lessons march 27 sabbath morning
will be covering the entire chapter so
hopefully that question and any other
question you have will be answered
by you tuning in to our sabbath school
lesson here at some tv
for this next march 27th all right let's
go on to our next question
this one comes to us as pastors thank
you for the fascinating question and
answer series my question is
what was the purpose or significance
of the pomegranate specifically on the
hem
of the priest's outer garment and then
they quote
exodus chapter 39 verses 22
to 30 and it basically says he was made
a robe of he fought of woven work
all of blue and there was an opening in
the middle of the robe like the opening
of a coat of mail
and uh with a woven binding all about
the opening so that's the head could
come through
and it has seam around it there so it
wouldn't tear
then they made of the hem of the rope
pomegranates a blue and purple and
scarlet of fine woven linen
and they made bells of pure gold and put
the bells between the pomegranates on
the hem of the robe
all about the pomegranates it was a bell
and a pomegranate a bell and a
pomegranate all around the hem of the
robe
to minister in as the lord had commanded
moses
and then the questionnaire says thank
you well there's a lot of significance
here
the whole sanctuary service was
significant it was symbolic
and it had a lot of representation for
example the altar in the courtyard
represented the altar of sacrifice or
calvary
where the lamb was slain signifying
jesus christ
the altar of incense in the holy place
represents prayers intercession
the show bread represents the word of
god and then you have the candlesticks
representing
representing witnessing so what are the
symbolisms here that we can find with
the pomegranate
and the bells well the pomegranate is a
fruit
and so fruit is a very significant part
of the christian life
in fact if you couple that with the bell
the bell was to make a noise as the
priest was
walking around doing his service there
so the noise would symbolize or
represent
the communication of the priest as he's
walking around whereas the pomegranate
would represent the fruits
and we see this in our lives today as
christians
in other words we are called to
communicate truth to
speak it but we're also called to bear
fruit for the truth that we speak
and in a very real sense we see this all
through the new testament
we are called to preach the gospel to
every kindred nation tongue and people
in matthew chapter 24 and verse 14
it says this gospel of the kingdom will
be preached to all the world
that's the bell part that's the the
voice part and then it says
as a witness to all nations that's the
fruit part
in other words it's not enough for us to
simply communicate the gospel
we also want to bear fruit that is in
harmony with that communication
let's look at a few bible verses so that
we can really make this clear in our
minds the first one we want to look at
is in matthew chapter 7 and we're going
to start there in verse 20.
matthew chapter 7 jesus here is speaking
about people who profess to follow him
or
know him who profess to do works in his
name
to to profess to acknowledge themselves
orally that is with their mouths that
they're his followers
and then he says here in verse 20
wherefore by their fruits you shall know
them
not everyone verse 21 that says unto me
lord lord shall enter into the kingdom
of heaven but he that
does the will of my father which is in
heaven so jesus here in matthew 7
20 and 21 is clarifying the difference
between saying
and doing not everyone that says is a
doer
and those that say but don't do are not
going to be
counted part of god's kingdom and so
jesus says by their fruits you're going
to know them it's not just going to be
by the
bell but it's also going to be by the
pomegranate the priest was to have
a bell and the pomegranate on the hem of
his garment
as he worshipped or as he ministered for
the lord and we are called to be priests
in fact
let's look at a couple verses that cover
that one of them is found in revelation
chapter 1
revelation chapter 1 the last book of
the new testament
revelation chapter 1 and verse 6.
it says here well let's start with verse
5 because it gives us a great context
it says and from jesus christ who is the
faithful witness and the first begotten
of the dead
the prince of the kings of the earth
unto him that loved us
and washed us from our sins in his own
blood verse 6
and hath made us kings and priests unto
god
and his father to him be glory and
dominion forever
and ever amen so we see here in
revelation chapter 1 verse 6 that we are
called to be priests
in fact if we go to another new
testament verse this one is found in
first
peter chapter two and verse nine first
peter chapter two and verse nine just
back
a few pages from revelation first peter
two verse nine
it says but ye are a chosen generation
a royal priesthood a holy nation
a peculiar people that ye should show
forth the praises of him who have called
you out of darkness
into his marvelous light so here even in
the context
not only does it say that we are a
chosen priesthood
a peculiar people but it says we are to
show
forth that is to to exhibit
to to bear fruit to him who's called us
out of darkness into this marvelous
light
so in the new testament we're called to
be priests just like the old testament
we are called to this priesthood of
believers and in that priest of
believers we are to be not just
verbalizing
the truth but we are to be bearing fruit
to the truth
let's look at a couple more verses that
talk about this there are so many verses
in the new testament that talk about the
importance of bearing fruit
and those verses are if you will
summarize in revelation
12 and verse 17 and revelation chapter
14 and verse 12 by a people that are
called the
remnant who keep the commandments of god
and have the testimony of jesus christ
or keep the commandments of god and have
the faith of jesus christ
commandment keeping is the ultimate
fruit that is
born in the believer's life but let's
look at a few more verses here the next
one we want to look at is in colossians
chapter 1.
just back a few verses from first peter
we find colossians chapter one it's
after
ephesians and philippians colossians 1
and let's look at the context here we'll
start with verse 5.
for the hope which is laid up for you in
heaven wherever you have heard before
in the word of truth of the gospel which
has come unto you
verse 6 as it is in all the world
and bringeth forth fruit as it does also
in you
since the day you heard of it and knew
of the grace of god in truth
and so here we find these verses
explaining to us
that the gospel the word of god in truth
brings forth fruit jesus warns us again
in matthew chapter 7
a lot of people are just going to say
lord lord but they don't have
fruit by their fruits you're going to
know them a lot of people are going to
say they love the lord but jesus says in
john 14 15
if you love me keep my commandments
that's the fruit
of our testimony so you've got the bell
the promagana you've got the noise
you've got the voice
you've got the testimony and you've got
the fruit and the fruit is
at every other stage in that
hem of that garment in other words there
was a pomegranate there was a bell
there's a pomegranate there's a bell
there's a pomegranate and there's a bell
they go hand in hand faith without works
is dead
faith works by love and so it brings
forth these works these fruits
and paul talks about that in galatians
and we want to look in galatians for our
last verse
galatians chapter 5 and verse 22.
galatians 5 and verse 22 here paul is
very specific
about the fruits of the spirit galatians
5 verse 22
he says but the fruit of the spirit
is love and joy and peace
and long-suffering and gentleness and
goodness and faith and
meekness and temperance against such
there is
no law and so you see romans tells us
that the law of god
convicts us of sin so that all the world
may become
guilty before god romans chapter 3 verse
19.
paul says here in galatians chapter 5
that when we have the fruits of the
spirit there's no law that condemns us
there's no law against that
because we are lining up with the
principles of god's law
when we reveal the fruits of the spirit
the fruits of the spirit are a
manifestation of god's love
and god's love is god's law is a
transcript of his character
that's why jesus says in matthew 22 that
love is summarized by loving god with
all our heart mind and soul and loving
our neighbor as ourselves let me
rephrase that
the law is summarized by loving god with
all our heart mind and soul
and loving our neighbor as ourselves and
you could find that in matthew
22 verses 36 6 through 40.
i said that was the last verse but let's
look at one more this one is in
philippians chapter 1
and verse 11 philippians 1 and verse 11.
it says here
in philippians 1 verse 11 being filled
with the fruits of righteousness which
are by jesus christ
unto the glory and praise of god now we
could spend
a lot of time on the fruits as you see
here these fruits are called the fruits
of righteousness of the fruits of right
doing
first john chapter 5 says that all
unrighteousness is sin and of course
in first john 3 4 it says sin is
transgression of the law
so there's no way around that fruit
bearing is part of the christian
experience
the priest in the old testament had the
fruit and the bell on the hem of
of the garment that he wore when he
ministered to the lord
we in the new testament are called to be
kings and priests
we're a peculiar nation a holy
priesthood and we according to
colossians 1 5 and 6 and according to
matthew 7
20 and 21 and according to philippians 1
and verse 11 and according to galatians
5 and verse 22 according to revelation
uh 14 and verse 12 and revelation 12 and
verse 17 and of course
according to christ's own words in john
chapter
14 and verse 15 we are to bear fruit we
are to bring forth the fruit of
love which is seen in commandment
keeping
worshipping goblet of heart mind and
soul and
loving people as we love ourselves so
this is what i believe the symbolism
is representing here at the on the hem
of the
garment of the priests in the sanctuary
service hopefully that's
answered the question uh enough for the
ask
okay let's go to our next question our
next question
is a difficult one it's a challenging
one it says frequently i'm having to
answer questions
from those concerning how to honor their
parents
by their works these adventist parents
profess to be christians now we just
talked about
people who profess to be christians but
may not be christians
and publicly they advertise that that
they
are for the that they are christians for
the purpose of looking good to receive
the praise of men however
this questioner says privately
privately they are the worst
advertisements of christianity
when they per habitually deceive
steal accuse exhort exploit
malign mistreat and demonstrate their
and demoralize excuse me their adult
sons and daughters claiming
parental authority alone further
complicating this ongoing issue
is the massive guilt that is used by the
parents against their children
when they assert that a failure to
comply with their endless
indiscriminate wants is a violation of
god's ten commandments specifically the
fifth commandment which says honor your
father and mother
what god the counsel would you suggest i
could offer to provide a more balanced
understanding of this commandment
and free from the enslavement the
suffering and anguished sons
and daughters of god well this is
a really interesting question and as
soon as i read it i thought to myself i
don't even want to tackle that question
that is so
complicated and difficult but then i
thought no you know we really need to
help
this young man this this questioner and
all of the young adults who may be
in a situation where they have parents
who are literally
violating the commandments of god
because that's what's taking place here
it says they are stealing accusing
exhorting exploiting maligning
they're literally violating the
commandments of god
and then they're quoting the commandment
one of the commandments of god
and telling the people that they're
violating these commandments against
that they need to honor them so in other
words they're breaking god's
commandments in the way they
treat their children and then they're
telling their children but you need to
honor us
because the commandments say the fifth
commandment says you need to honor your
father and your mother
and my response to that would be i mean
basically if you think about this
here are parents that are violating the
commandments
and then quoting one of them to try to
support their
violation of the other commandments
toward their children
and there is no obligation to honor
parents
who are violating the commandments and
using a commandment to try to support
their violation of those other
commandments
in their relationship with you and in
the way that they treat you
in fact the best way to honor parents
who are in such situations who are
treating you in this way i would say
would be to refuse to support them when
they are
willingly and deliberately violating the
other commandments that god has given
you can't just quote commandments to
your pleasure
that will support what you're doing
especially if it's in violation of other
commandments
the commandments are a chain they're a
whole if you break one of those
commandments you break
all of those commandments and it's not
right proper it's not righteous good
or just for you to claim to be
keeping the commandments of god while
you violate one or more of those
commandments
it's not right or just or proper for you
to claim
that people should listen to you and
obey you and support you
in violation of of other commandments
when using the commandments to violate
other commandments
i think it's clear what i'm saying here
in other words
we as parents we need to be honoring all
of god's commandments if we expect to
quote those commandments
to those our children specifically who
we are asking to honor us and if we are
violating those commandments and
especially violating them
in relation to our children then no
honor
is due us the only honor that should be
due us
is for our children to get up enough
nerve enough guts enough
love uh faithful of the wounds of a
friend but the
kisses of enemy are deceitful enough
genuine love to rebuke us and say hey
you should not be living in violation of
these other commandments and causing
us to support you in the violation of
those commandments and
quote the commandments in order to to do
that that just is not appropriate
whatsoever
all right difficult question but i hope
the answer there
is is helpful our next question
is is it wrong for a christian to
practice
yoga now before i answer this question i
just want to say
um pastor bohr you know had an
obligation today something else that he
had to do and so
when he came to my office and and told
me i need to do the program alone
he handed me these questions uh to
answer and as i started reading through
the questions i said
huh wow i wish you would be on this
program with me to help me with some of
these questions because these are
challenging questions
and uh you know i started to almost
question where he was going and what he
was doing but
i know he's on a zoom call he's doing an
important study
at this time and so he couldn't be with
us but again i just wanted to
you know and in other words i almost
thought man i can't do these questions i
got to
figure out some other questions to do
but then i thought no i need to pray
about this
these are honest questions people are
asking them they need answers to these
questions so i'll do my best
to answer this question it's going to be
a little bit challenging but we'll look
at a few bible verses that may help
i've never practiced yoga so it's going
to be hard for me to speak to this
practically
but i have practiced another form
of exercise that i struggled with
is it right or wrong and that was
martial arts is it wrong to practice
yoga so i put
you know my immediate answer was oh
stretching regular exercise
no it's great to be in shape it's great
to stretch i know yoga does a lot of
stretching i know when i was in martial
arts
i did a lot of stretching a lot of
exercises that were really good for me i
felt like i was in good shape
but there's a very key element in
martial arts and a very key
element in yoga that i think is strictly
forbidden
by the word of god and that element is
meditation
and the reason why that's forbidden is
because meditation at least for martial
arts the way i practice it there and my
understanding is
also for yoga because my martial arts
sensei my martial arts instructor
was into yoga and brought that into the
martial arts
training that he gave to us the
meditation that they're recommending
is to empty your mind of all thoughts
just completely empty it now this is in
a direct contradiction
to the kind of meditation that we're
called to practice
in the word of god the meditation that
the word of god calls us to practice
is a meditation on the word of god we
find this over and over again
in the bible david says makes phrases
statements like this
your law has been my meditation day and
night i will
meditate on the goodness of god all of
my days in other words
in the bible we are meditating on
something
we're not emptying our mind of
everything we are actually placing our
mind on something in fact
we're we are closing out the world and
the distractions of the world
to our minds so that we can focus and
meditate on those things that
have to do with god's word god's truth
the light and truth of the bible the
light and truth of heaven
and so it's not it's exactly the
opposite of the kind of medication
meditation that will call you to empty
your mind to
to to take out all of your thoughts and
so the danger there that i want to share
with you
is found in a couple of bible verses
that we're going to look at the first
one
is found in matthew chapter 12 and we're
going to look here in matthew chapter 12
beginning with verse 43 so if you'd like
to open your bibles there to matthew
chapter
12 and we'll start in verse 43.
matthew 12 43 jesus is speaking here and
he says now when the unclean spirit is
gone out of a man
he walks through dry places seeking rest
and findeth none
so this is talking about someone who has
been emptied of the unclean spirit
they've been empty of the world
okay the the world has gone out of them
there and but they're looking around
they're seeking to find rest and it says
verse
44 says then he saith i will return unto
my house from whence i came out
and when he has come he finds it empty
swept
and garnished now this is
a unique kind of um object lesson that
christ is sharing here about what
happens when someone is
freed from the world and free from the
spirits
of the world and darkness freed from the
spirits of the devil and the enemy
and his house is cleaned out and the
spirit is gone
but there's nothing put into the house
the house is empty
which is very similar to the idea of
meditation
in relationship to martial arts in
relationship to yoga in relationship to
um
to eastern mysticism in relationship to
spiritual formations in relationship to
to the new age movement where you empty
everything out of you you empty every
thought out
which is completely contrary to what the
bible tells us meditation is all about
when you meditate in the bible you
meditate on something you don't meditate
everything out so you're not meditating
about you're not emptying yourself
jesus says when you empty yourself out
even if the bad stuff goes
even if you're trying to meditate all
the bad stuff out let's just say you're
doing a meditation
you know i used to do it for martial
arts time and i'm trying to empty my
brain of all of the stress and all of
the trouble and all of the pain and all
the difficulty that i've been through
through the day so i'm trying to get
that all that stuff out so it's all gone
but there's nothing in there my mind is
empty and so when all that bad stuff
goes out jesus is saying here in verse
when all that bad stuff goes out the
the bad stuff is gone but then it comes
back again and it comes back in greater
force
because your mind is empty therefore it
becomes
open to even more garbage that can come
in
even greater a greater amount of
spiritual energy or negative spiritual
energy though we may not recognize it as
such
to come in so jesus says we shouldn't
leave our minds empty you don't want
you don't just want to clean it all out
when i became a christian i didn't just
get the bad stuff out the rock and roll
and all of the images
and all of the the things that my brain
the habits that my brain were in tune
with that were
contrary to the word of god i started
filling my brain
filling my mind with the god's truth
with the word of god with the truths of
god's word i started reading the bible
and listening to sermons and
listening to pastors and doing bible
studies and being engaged in the word of
god
so that not only was the bad stuff going
out but good stuff was coming in
and the most important good stuff that
we can bring into our minds
is jesus christ because jesus christ
we're told in john chapter 1
is the word made flesh he is the word of
god
and so when we bring jesus in we bring
the word of god and when we bring the
word of god and we bring jesus in
so let's turn to our next bible verse
this one is found in
revelation chapter 3 and verse
21. so the last book of the bible the
book of revelation
chapter 23 excuse me chapter 3 and verse
revelation chapter 3 and verse 21
actually verse 20.
revelation 3 and verse 20. jesus is
speaking to the laodicean church here
and he says behold i stand at the door
and knock
if any man hear my voice and open the
door
i will come in with him and sup with him
and he with me
now this is an amazing summary of
everything we've just talked about in
relationship to meditation
basically filling our minds with the
word of god is filling our minds with
jesus
jesus here is depicting himself as
standing outside a church
that is described with the name laodicea
that's a church that is
lukewarm hot and cold hot and cold
sunday it's hot some days it's cold some
days it's hot sometimes it's cold
and when you get hot days you get cold
days you mix them together you've got
lukewarm
god doesn't want us to have hot days and
cold days on hot days and cold days
because that lukewarm experience makes
them want to throw up
god wants us to be hot hot hot hot for
him or cold because sometimes it's
easier for god to reach us when we're
cold than it is when we're lukewarm
because the latest seeing condition of
lukewarmness
doesn't feel its need of jesus it feels
rich and increasing with goods and in
need of
nothing and that's why jesus is on the
outside knocking
he wants to have entrance into the
laodicean church
when you meditate in the eastern
religious
type of sense the new age type of center
emptying your mind of everything
god doesn't want christians to empty
their mind of everything god wants
christians to keep their minds
filled with the word of god with the
truths of god's word to meditate on the
truth of god's word
to let jesus in and always have him in
so when those spirits come back
when those unclean thoughts come back
and they do we get thoughts that hammer
the best of us
we can ask jesus to answer the door when
those things come knocking on our door
the door of our brain the door of our
heart when those negative thoughts when
those evil thoughts when those
past thoughts and images come knocking
on the door
we can say jesus could you answer that
for us and jesus
when he answers the door those evil
spirits are gone those thoughts are gone
when we lift our minds to heaven we lift
our thoughts to
heaven god will attract our thoughts
like a magnet and help us to keep our
thoughts directed to him
all right i hope that's a good enough
answer for those who ask this question
we are out of time
but again we want to remind you send
your questions to tv
at some tv.org.org if you'd like to know
and we'll do our very best to answer
those questions
from the bible god bless
[Music]
you